let's talk about Donald Trump's income a
very very strange statement made by
Donald Trump's lawyers over the weekend
the president Donald Trump's lawyers now
say that in looking at the last ten
years of tax returns there are no forms
of income of any type from Russian
sources with some exceptions which based
on my understanding of the English
language means that there are Russian
income sources on Donald Trump's tax
returns over the last ten years this is
sort of like saying I've never killed
anyone in my life with some exceptions
which means you have killed some people
in your life the letter says there's no
equity investment by Russians in
entities controlled by Donald Trump or
debt owed by Donald Trump to Russian
lenders but that it does reflect income
from the 2013 Miss Universe pageant
which was held in Moscow as well as a
property sold to a Russian billionaire
in 2008 for ninety five million dollars
so no Russian income other than you know
a hundred million or so dollars some
exceptions as Donald Trump's lawyers are
calling them the White House is saying
Trump went to his lawyers and asked for
this letter after a request from
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham of
South Carolina who heads one of the
congressional committees investigating
Russian interference in the election
this is just so bizarre to me if they're
commenting about what is in the tax
returns does that mean that the tax
returns are no longer being audited
which Donald Trump said as soon as the
audits are done I'll release the tax
returns or are we going to forget about
that and just continue to take Donny boy
at his word it's sort of an odd release
first of all because it does make Donald
Trump look very defensive because it's
very strange wording absolutely no
Russian income with about a hundred
million dollars in exceptions secondly
it's calling attention to the reality
that Donald Trump never released his tax
returns which is something nearly
three-quarters of Americans want to see
some exceptions is a nice line Donald
Trump is making America great again with
some exceptions I kind of like that the
timing of it is weird and one thing that
occurred to me is maybe pre-empting some
future article that is going to be a
blockbuster with regard to Donald
Trump's Russian revenues or liabilities
or debts or whatever the case may be
it's also yet another thing to look at
and this has mentioned before it's not
new that ninety five million dollar
condo that Donald Trump sold to a
Russian oligarch it's pretty sketchy
because it was purchased for just 40
million dollars a few years before what
was done to more than double the value
of it that method of selling a property
for way more than it appears maybe to be
worth that is a ripe method for money
laundering and it's this letter only
raises suspicions and we've heard such
conflicting statements from Trump and
his kids over the last 10 years about
how much business do they do with Russia
that this all stinks and I would not be
surprised if this is trying to preempt
some really damaging reliefs that we're
going to be seeing could be days could
be weeks or months from now